[Musique
] c'est de loin la chose la plus dangereuse
que nous ayons jamais tentée,
nous travaillons dessus depuis des années,
nous allons le tourner en Norvège et
ce sera un saut en moto d'une falaise
dans un saut de base
Je veux le faire depuis que je suis un petit
enfant, tout se résume à une chose,
le public
y va beaucoup dans cette cascade, alors
Tom a élaboré ce plan directeur pour
coordonner tous ces experts dans chacune
des disciplines particulières impliquées
pour faire cela  tout se passe John et
moi sautons de l'hélicoptère il
va me chasser c'est ce que nous nous
disons ne soyez pas prudent soyez confiant
soyez confiant
un an de formation de base guide avancé
formation beaucoup de compétences de voilure beaucoup
de suivi  Tom Cruise ces individus incroyables,
vous leur dites quelque chose et
il le verrouille simplement dans son sens de la conscience spatiale,
il est la personne la plus consciente
que j'ai jamais rencontrée,
beaucoup de pratique sur la stabilité et le
trekking en chute libre avec John et des kilomètres dans les
airs faisant beaucoup  positionnement ent
comme s'il y avait deux hommes en équipe dans les airs
venant l'un au-dessus de l'autre en dessous l'un de l'
autre reculant suivi frontal vous
savez que nous avons percé et percé et
percé
lorsque vous faites beaucoup de sauts dos à dos
les compétences de contrôle de la voilure s'améliorent beaucoup
nous avons trois auvents ouverts, ce qui est une
bonne chose que
l'entraînement se soit très bien passé c'est
massivement progressif
merci comment allez-vous super journée mec
c'est la prochaine partie de l'entraînement ici
au Motocross faisons-le
donc nous avons construit une piste de motocross en
obtenant des comps  le motocross donc il est
confortable en sautant sur une table de 70 à 80 pieds un bon
moment dans les airs un excellent positionnement sur le
monde du vélo et de l'
atterrissage  monter avec la
cascade n'est qu'un des
défis techniques l'autre consiste à placer une caméra
dans un endroit où vous pouvez voir où Tom le
fait trouver le bon objectif la
bonne plate-forme le bon support même t
il y a deux ans, les caméras n'existaient pas, ce
qui nous permettrait de faire ce que nous essayons
de faire aujourd'hui, comment impliquons-nous le
public, je veux juste leur donner ce
frisson qui signifie que la caméra doit
être devant Tom et comme  près de lui que
possible, on a l'impression que vous passez par-dessus
la caméra oui très cool,
entraînez-vous et percez chaque petit aspect encore
et encore et encore et encore, ils
faisaient 30 sauts par jour pour arriver à un
point où il n'était qu'une machine je veux dire
plus de 500 sauts en parachute
c'est ce que nous faisons
plus de 13 000 sauts de motocross
[Musique] d'
accord ça va être amusant oh c'est
génial
reproduit cette rampe en Angleterre dans une
carrière nous avons rempli la carrière de
boîtes en carton qui étaient là pour
attraper la moto la raison pour laquelle nous
est-ce pour que Tom puisse simuler
la jungle à quelle vitesse dois-je partir quelle
distance dois-je parcourir nous avons construit des modèles
de différentes rampes à différents angles
pour calculer quelle serait la trajectoire de Tom
nous devons être en mesure de
prédire de manière cohérente où Tom i  s va être dans
un espace tridimensionnel, nous allons
avoir une puce GPS sur moi et qui a enregistré
chacun des sauts de Tom
avec sa vitesse au sol s'il y avait
un vent de face s'il y avait un vent de travers
et en faisant cela plusieurs fois  nous avons
pu obtenir un ensemble cohérent de données afin
que chaque prise nous permette de voir à quelle hauteur je
me trouve, de cette façon nous pouvons placer des drones et des
caméras dans des endroits où je peux aller directement
dans la règle de gros plan on ne me frappe pas avec
ça  parce que si nous faisons tout, nous ne le
captons pas correctement, à quoi bon faisons-le,
les gars, prêt, oui,
portez toujours mes bouchons d'oreille pour ne pas
m'entendre crier,
nous sommes prêts, prêts à
certaines vitesses et cohérents avec
cela, il n'y a pas de compteur de vitesse, donc je  faites-le
par le son et la sensation du vélo
et alors que je quitte le vélo, j'utilise un
vent qui me frappe ici et je
serre ma poitrine qui me donnera des ascenseurs
[Musique]
vous tous beaucoup pour votre aide les gars
[Applaudissements  ]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes ici en Norvège,
nous avons construit cette rampe vo  euh un
certain nombre de mois, tout ici doit
être apporté par des ingénieurs
et des techniciens d'hélicoptères, c'est incroyable ce
qu'ils ont fait, c'est magistral aujourd'hui, c'est le premier
jour de la photographie principale et
nous commençons dans le forum de mission classique
avec la plus grande cascade du film quoi
ce que nous faisons ici, c'est que je fais juste des sauts
juste pour réchauffer le corps, faisons-le
juste pour faire avancer mon suivi et s'assurer
que tout fonctionne bien,
essayez de ne pas sourire en
gros quand il descend et met un
parachute autour et s'en va  et fait le
travail à vélo, il connaîtra en fait les
conditions météorologiques dans cette zone dans la vallée
et sur le terrain
[Musique]
puis il demande de déployer un parachute en toute sécurité
maintenant il est dans une boule de roche avec des murs tout
autour de lui et il doit  envolez-
vous bien sûr, vous savez quand quelque chose a été
fait pour la première fois, vous ne pouvez pas vous empêcher de
vous inquiéter un peu de la façon dont cela
va vraiment se passer avec un saut
comme celui-ci, le défi est de trouver les
caméras c'est l'amo  unt de préparation
et ensuite il fait temps vous voulez que la
lumière soit bonne vous voulez que les nuages ​​soient
bons Misty mais pas brumeux ce
temps ici est exactement ce que nous recherchons
à
environ 10 minutes de venir
ici atterrir et faire le réel
les pensées sonnent bien nous sommes en
mouvement à bientôt maintenant nous allons définir les
cadres de ce vaisseau caméra avec le
drone juste pour vérifier tout ce que
nous allons préparer
vous savez les seules choses que vous devez vraiment
éviter en faisant  une cascade comme celle-ci
est une blessure grave ou la mort, c'est parti,
vous conduisez une moto qui est
assez dangereuse au sommet d'une rampe
surélevée par rapport au sol, donc si vous
sortez de la rampe, ce sera très grave,
vous tombez  si vous n'obtenez pas une
sortie propre du vélo et que vous vous
emmêlez avec si vous n'ouvrez pas votre
parachute, alors vous n'allez pas en faire
trois deux un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci mec je pense que je peux tenir  le
vélo un peu plus longtemps
[Musique] à
peu près la plus grande cascade de l'
histoire du cinéma
Tom Cruise vient de monter une moto d'une
falaise six fois aujourd'hui
[Musique]
étranger
la chose la plus dangereuse que nous ayons jamais
tentée
la seule chose qui me fait peur  plus est
ce que nous avons prévu d'autoriser